- You take forever to get ready.
- I do.
- Now I'm gonna be that person.
(playful music)
We've been friends for seven years?
- Yea, living together for five.
- We've been friends since
freshman year of high school.
A little over 10 years.
- Today, we're going to start
a clothing swap for a week.
- Which is really exciting 'cause I think
she dresses better than me, so.
- I'm so nervous.
I think I'm gonna hate this.
- I feel like our styles
are really different.
- We used to have the
same wardrobe, in college.
- Basically, my sense of
style has not changed at all,
and Linda's has gotten
way more fashionable.
I'm very much about being able to grab
whatever I want out of my wardrobe
and just like slap it together.
- She's not afraid of like mixing prints,
which I'm really excited about.
- My expectations for this week is,
I kind of feel like I
might dress how I like do
when I have a cold.
- I feel like she's much
better at being like a woman,
than I am, so I feel like I'm gonna be
much more in touch with feminine whiles.
- I'm so excited to
dress you up like a doll.
(festive music)
- [Voiceover] Look at all the clothes
Linda has picked out for me.
It is crazy and this
isn't even all of them.
This is a very bright
color, it's very sheer.
My midriff is otherwise
bare with a very thin sheet
of fabric between me and the elements.
- I feel like it...
looks like I only had like
five minutes to get ready.
- My grandma, my mom,
everybody has been saying,
"you look so cute today."
Everybody's been saying actually
that I look like I've lost weight.
- I wore the dress, as
I'm trying to do that,
I'm just showing you boobs.
I got the most compliments
on my outfit since Halloween.
- This is the first day I've
been wearing Linda's clothes
at work and I am kinda nervous.
I feel like my butt is hanging out,
'cause I never wear leggings as pants.
We'll see what my co-workers think.
- It, ok, it doesn't look bad on her,
it just, it looks like Linda.
- He laughed at me.
- So I'm going on a date.
I am comfortable, I don't quite remember
why I hated on jeans so much.
I mean, I do have to say,
I would probably promote me
in these clothes rather than
if I was wearing my clothes.
- I've literally never
worn a crop top before.
I keep wanting to tuck
it in and pull it down.
- [Linda] Nope, nope, nope.
- The layer game is strong but I never
layer stuff like this.
I just feel a little constricted.
- So I did not blog yesterday,
but you'll see a photo hopefully
of what I wore yesterday.
I felt like such a woman, like whoa.
- I realized one of the reasons
that I don't usually wear vests,
is that I'm very self
conscious about my upper arms.
Which I'm starting to
realize was really stupid
'cause vests are really great,
because they cover your boobs
so you don't have to wear like a real bra.
- Appreciating my silhouette
more than I usually do,
'cause I have to wear a real bra
instead of a sports bra and a vest.
- I'm wearing my favorite Sara sweater.
This is one of the ones I was like,
"ooh I can't wait to wear this."
- I've never paid attention to what
I wear so much in a week.
It's kind of exhausting.
- I'm starting to get
a lot more comfortable
in someone else's clothes,
literally and figuratively.
- The first day, you were
making this face the whole time,
but I feel like you're
starting to really rock it
and get your swagger on
- I'm feeling myself in this
outfit, I'm feeling myself.
(funky music)
- I feel bad for what I said previously.
I learned that classic
fashion makes me much happier
than I thought it would.
- It was really funny
'cause she looked better
in all my clothes than I did.
- It's a lot more color
than I would ever wear.
- I feel like I learned how
to be braver with fashion.
I was scared of crop tops
and flowy things before.
- Her sweater game is like next-level.
- Let's kick up my top
sock, so I have to--
- You have to cover it?
- Definitely took less time
to get ready, which was great.
- At the beginning, I was so excited.
As the week went on, I was like,
"I just want my clothes
back, all my tops."
- Like literally every
outfit you picked out for me
had at least one element
that made me really
uncomfortable at first.
By the end of the week
though, I was definitely
feeling a lot more comfortable.
And I was just like, "eh
whatever it'll be fine."
- What would be awesome is
if we could share clothes
all the time now
- We both decided that when we shop,
we have to go together.
- If Linda was gonna
dress me every morning,
then yea sure, I would
layer, but dont, no.
I dunno, I like this one, this one's nice.
- I love this on you.
- Does a lot for my boobs.
- I just keep checking out your chest,
I'm glad you brought it
up 'cause I didn't want
to be creepy, but your
cleavage looks amazing.